red wine it's a multi-billion dollar
industry inna files wax on about the
look or smell the feel the taste but
what's actually inside red wine for
starters volatile compounds like three
isobutyl to the foxy receipt or ibmp it
gives Cabernet Sauvignon its herbaceous
green pepper aroma and of course ethanol
that magical mood altering chemicals
makes you feel good and then bad if you
drink to death anole is the product of
fermentation when you eats the sugar in
grapes they excrete carbon dioxide and
ethanol all this stuff comes from grape
juice but a lot of what inside red wine
actually comes from the skins and seeds
malvert and three glucoside a pigment in
grape skin gives red wine its color
tannins our astringent molecules that
bind to saliva proteins and make your
tongue feel dry resveratrol this
antioxidant may actually fight cancer
and tame diabetes so go ahead have
another glass feeling wired yet
subscribe